robots today operate under very limited
conditions they work in the laboratory
under very carefully controlled
situations what we want to do is we want
to move these robots out of the
laboratory and into schools and homes
and clinics places where we can directly
help children on a day-to-day basis
my name's Brian Scott Scotty and I'm a
computer scientist here at Yale
University over the next five years I'll
be working with colleagues at
universities across the country in order
to build robots that can help children
we're just starting out on this
brand-new five-year project that's being
supported by the National Science
Foundation under the expedition's in
computing program will be working with
colleagues both here at Yale and at
universities across the u.s. in order to
try to bring this technology into
people's homes there are many challenges
in trying to bring this kind of
technology into people's homes and to do
it in a way that is directly supporting
these children we're going to have to
deal with systems that are able to learn
and adapt over long periods of time
we're going to need to develop systems
that can recognize and respond to the
social cues that the children produce
we're going to need systems that can
understand how it is that we motivate
individuals toward a specific goal in
order to do this we need robots that can
respond and change to the child over a
long period of time that's something
that we're not able to do with computing
technology today but we need systems
that can adapt to the individual
preferences of the child that can guide
a child toward a long term behavioral
goal and that are able to do this in a
way that is fun and appealing and
motivating just like a good personal
trainer we want the robots to be able to
guide the child toward a behavior that
we desire we want them to help the
children learn language we want to help
them learn better eating habits we want
them to learn new social or cognitive
skills through their interactions with
these robots and the robots will be
supporting all the efforts that we
already have with human therapists and
their parents
their communities the robots will
supplement those activities and allow us
to give children more continuous and
more detailed support so robots today
can change and respond and learn from
very simple social cues and from very
simple situations what we want to do is
to find ways in which we can enable this
technology to work over longer periods
of time and in a more generalized
setting if we're successful in this we
think that we can make a real difference
in the lives of children and we think
that we can produce some of the most
interesting the most engaging and the
most competent social robots that we've
ever seen
you